when you see Larry Fink and the rest of
them pushing these esgs it's essentially
you've got a bunch of Wall Street
Boomers that are saying oh we've got
nine trillion dollars in assets as a
money management firm so how do we then
impose our vision of this Utopia on
everybody else while they come up with
these esgs and if you want access to
that Capital you've got to go along with
your Corporate social credit score
what's ESG mean environmental social
governance
what is it exactly it's a corporate
social credit score so it's the idea
it's a score that even Zuckerberg is
going to be under so even Twitter is
going to be under that if you it's it's
based it's literally like a corporate
social credit corporate social credit of
course and it's and it's I'm happy you
brought this up because I remember
researching this a little bit and then
fully understanding yes the great reset
but it's also the woke agenda it it
explains why some of so many of these
same policies are kind of brought out in
unison by all these very powerful forces
all at once and they kind of double down
on them but that's why we see the pope
literally work with MasterCard and visa
and meet with them in order to push for
the great reset in order to try to
implement it as fast as they can and
again they outline everything they're
doing it's in their own documents it's
on their website they brag about it the
world economic Forum literally makes it
very clear about super futuristic videos
about how glorious everything's going to
be how fun everything's going to be how
convenient and better everything's going
to be when you know you just you just
give up those pesky rights you just give
up those pesky civil liberties and
Liberties yes of course yeah that was uh
here here's the most important takeaway
though they're doing a new Kingsman
right yeah third one yeah that's a
prequel though right I think in the
movie Kingsman a tech billionaire is
trying to figure out how to stop global
warming by having the poor people all
Purge themselves and he gives the elites
a device to protect them but the most
important takeaway from that film is
that the leader of Kingsman is in on it
right so when you get the pope coming
out like the the leaders are all like
agreeing about this listen I actually
pulled this up before I came out today
World economic Forum 2016 from the
global future councils
welcome to the year 2030. Welcome To My
City or should I say our city what I
don't own anything I don't own a car I
don't own a house I don't own any
appliances or clothes it might seem odd
to you but it makes perfect sense for us
in this city everything you considered a
product has now become a service that's
most common so like when you wake up a
guy clothes you or what no it's like so
borrowing no it's like you rent you'll
rent clothes like the way you run a
talks or there's like Rent the Runway
it's already started right so what about
retirement
retirement and then you have them for
like a week you wear the clothes then
you put them back to the service then
you get the next one and if you say I
hate the government they take your
clothes away yeah exactly yeah they shut
off your ability to be able to buy stuff
to be able to go do you want to open
market if you want to open your smart
fridge are they going to like try an
electrically shock brains to pacify
people is that well I I haven't read
anything about that in the world
economic Forum documents and what they
kind of strive to achieve but
everything's out there on their website
they did delete that one famous article
where they said you will own nothing you
will have no privacy and you will be
happier than ever they deleted that so
you have to actually go and they try to
say like oh no this was a submission
into a thing and it wasn't like your
logo is on the video but they're
literally talking about controlling so
many aspects of your existence I mean
Bill Gates is literally this is the
clear yeah yeah Bill Gates is of course
on board with this he's working and
financing technology that will literally
have implantable microchips that will
control if you could have children with
an on and off button yes look up Bill
Gates microchips funding in a way that
could control your fertility on and off
through electricity so so they're
working on control I don't believe you I
don't care the fertility chip yes yes if
no this is a false claim from Reuters no
that was all the false claim was about
coronavir virus yes so so some people
are conflating this with coronavirus it
has nothing to do with coronavirus what
is this what is this this is what I'm
talking about this is what Bill Gates is
financing he's literally financing
it's a birth control exact pregnancy
track that people no no no hold on hold
on hold on I got no problem with you
saying that Bill Gates wants to create a
chip that can turn off fertility exactly
but as long as you you give us the full
framing of it yes Bill Gates is working
on what they say is a pregnancy tracking
app and uh well I don't know what this
website is glass room and fertility
activity they say some invasive blah
blah the general idea is that women
would be able to have birth control or
something no no not just that it's about
controlling fertility with an on and off
button that someone else will control so
this is another remote control
contraceptive chip available by 20 yes
thank you thank you uh all right in the
articles in 2014. now right it's from
2014 they say the chip isn't planned
under a woman's skin releasing a small
dose of Levon or gestural of hormone
birth control this will happen every day
for 16 years but can be stopped at any
time by using a wireless remote control
the Project's been has been backed by
Bill Gates there's a big difference
between some a woman wanting birth
control and being like I can turn it off
when I decide to have a kid and Bill
Gates financing this yeah it doesn't say
that you can turn it off all I'm saying
is Bill Gates is financing this and Bill
Gates is all along with this great
economic uh you know the great reset
he's going along with this agenda and
he's creating technological Evolutions
we're talking about literally uh VR so
what makes you think that this is not
going to be a part they are going to
force you to not be able to have kids
when in reality people choosing not to
have kids yes and no on certain levels
because if they're controlling your
existence through VR what makes you
think that they won't move into another
step I mean this is technology that
China would have loved to have a few
years ago that they would have
implemented right away so whenever
talking about VR headsets and
controlling our reality by the way this
is this is another layer to it that
people need to understand because there
is a large portion of people pushing
this that do talk about the need of
reducing the world population of getting
rid of of people because they pollute
and we have to have climate change
effective green policies that get rid of
people so when you have Bill Gates being
able to create a technology that could
turn people's fertility on and off you
know that switch that power is something
that we should be talking about
especially when it comes to you know
theorizing I'm not saying this is going
to happen directly but I'm saying the
technology is being built their plans
are kind of out there in their own
websites on their own documents they're
talking about it themselves so when
they're implementing a lot of this you
should be concerned and you should raise
questions that's all I'm saying when I
I'm not saying I have a pro I have a
prophecy of what's going to happen here
because no one does that reminds your
story so when I lived in China
um I was visiting
um it was a friend of mine who had
basically an uncle that lived out in the
countryside from Shanghai and in the
county where he lived he had one of the
largest factories and he ran it and ran
it very well it was a toy factory and
because he ran it so well the uh the
county party chairman wanted to reward
him and as a reward he was allowed to
have a second child yes so and I
remember meeting you know and this is
just you know my my friend's uncle and
his two kids and I remember just hanging
out with the family and were just you
know playing around doing whatever but
then sitting there thinking that this
human being this person that I'm like
just you know rolling the ball back and
forth with they exist because the
Chinese Communist Party decided that due
to your loyalty and your allele service
to the party and to the country that you
can be allowed to create an extra life
exactly and had he not by the way they
would have taken it away and the same
globalist that that implemented and
inspired and put into place the child
the Chinese one-child policy that
implemented that everything that has
China become are the same people or the
same minds or the same quote
intellectuals behind the world
economically my theory of the case as
well exactly the world economic forum
and the great reset are America and the
West's answer to the CCP program in the
authoritarian they want they want the
system to live like like people are
living in China right now credit scores
and they're going to bring layers to
this that are mind-boggling and at first
people think you're crazy when you bring
up what they could potentially do to you
but but when they have the technology
when they're building this we have to
start asking here's the difference the
difference is in the west because we
have a tradition of personal choice that
they don't have in the East there will
be it won't necessarily be that they can
control the remote they'll tell but
they'll sit there and say oh you should
do this it'll be better for the country
it'd be better for the environment
better for the planet better for the
future this is the anti-natalist
movement or cancel culture right will
come up so all of these various
propaganda campaigns will be pushed
throughout Society
um you'll see propaganda movies you'll
see propaganda Netflix you'll see
propaganda TV shows all talking about
pushing these issues that go along well
it's a combination it's like Brave New
World that they do it through uh
pleasure and 1984. it's a combination of
both worlds coming together yesterday I
said it was like Revenge of the Nerds
and 1984 but in reality when you look at
the techniques that they're using to
pacify the general public a lot of them
brainwashing them and and there's also a
part of it it's the carrot in the stick
and that's how they are going to
implement a lot I know exactly what to
say to bring up what Luke is talking
about because it's through the lens of
something that we're seeing every day
look at what they're saying about the
unvaccinated look at the way they're
saying that unvaccinated people should
not be given priority in hospitals now
what happens if unvaccinated people go
to the hospital and they say oh I need a
C-section I'm having a problem with my
pregnancy I need an emergency C-section
oh but you're unvaccinated
yep right what happens then yeah there's
a really well Well ma'am if we continue
down social credit score is actually
quite impressive but your baby is
registering a zero and we can't help the
baby if that's the case it's already
happening in Italy there's a lot of guys
we were talking about the video
yesterday there's people being denied
Medical Services there's people being
denied organ transplants in the United
States because let's be honest here they
don't have the right social credit score
paper please approval system by the
federal government and and when we're
living in a society that's already this
divisive this discriminatory or they're
saying die unless do what the government
wants you to do I mean this is a level
that it's it's very hard to go back from
Luke you just go to the government
website you don't even have to think you
don't even have to think exactly that's
that's that's that's the thinking that's
going to lead us down to living like the
average person in China right now